p afghans et américains voient peut-être
la lumière au bout du tunnel
sébastien et cet accord prend sans doute
tout son sens quand on mesure un peu
l'ampleur des pertes de pertes de part
et d'autre des pertes de vies humaines
d'abord bien sûr c'est le premier
constat un constat qui vous allez voir
est assez choquant bon les états unis
ont été appuyés par une force
internationale dont les pays sont
représentés en bleu sur cette carte une
coalition d'ong qui a subi de lourdes
pertes
à commencer par les américains bien sûr
à qui déplore la mort de plus de 2400
soldats depuis 2001
voyez le royaume uni c'est la deuxième
force la plus éprouvée suivi du canada
tout juste derrière c'est trop beaucoup
trop
mais tout de même beaucoup moins que le
nombre de victimes chez les forces
afghanes qui combattent elle aussi les
talibans envoyé dans l'armée dans la
police on compterait de 60 mille
victimes depuis 2001 et autres les
soldats bien sûr il ya des civils dans
la population on compte près de quarante
mille morts a pris donc dans ces combats
depuis 17 ans maintenant pour un triste
bilan très ce total de plus de cent
quarante sept mille victimes de la
guerre en afghanistan et c'est un
conflit qui a coûté extrêmement cher aux
américains notamment
selon l'administration bush je devais
être court et relativement peu coûteux
or c'est devenu la guerre la plus longue
de l'histoire des états unis est l'une
des plus coûteuses des dépenses céline
qui ne se comptent pas en millions ni en
milliards de dollars
mais bien en billion un million et demi
de dollars ses 1500 milliards de dollars
canadiens si vous préférez une facture
qui se divise en trois segments si vous
voulez bon les opérations sur le terrain
l'entraînement des forces afghanes et
puis les dépenses et aux vétérans de
l'armée américaine il ya que la guerre
en irak et la seconde guerre mondiale
qui auront coûté plus cher dans
l'histoire des états unis toute cette
mobilisation militaire en europe a
permis de sécuriser le pays c'est ça qui
tout de même ironique les talibans
contrôlent aujourd'hui plus de
territoire que jamais depuis 2001 à
voyez ils détiennent tout ce qui est en
bourgogne sur cette carte le reste est
un territoire contesté ou contrôlées par
le gouvernement voici peut-être un
portrait un peu plus clair
du territoire taliban qui est enfoncée
ici comme nous le disait sylvain dans
son reportage un territoire de près de
15 millions de personnes là c'est
presque la moitié de la population est
un autre triste constate depuis dix ans
nombre de victimes d'attentats
terroristes ne cesse d'augmenter dans le
pays en 2010 est l'afghanistan est
devenu le pays où le nombre de victimes
d'attentats terroristes est le plus
élevé avec près de 4700 un bilan qui
incite on imagine les états unis a
quitté la coalition aujourd'hui oui
c'est ça le plan de match merci beaucoup
c'est facile vous en prie